he was the first man in u.s history to
hijack a plane for ransom
he left out of a commercial jet
with a parachute
two hundred thousand dollars
and was never seen again
dead
or alive
the mystery has frustrated the fbi for
nearly forty years i think he was just a
sleazy rotten criminal but has given the
public
a lasting legend
[Applause]
who was d.b cooper
did he survive
now for the first time
new scientific evidence could finally
help unravel the mystery of d.b cooper
[Music]
it's the eve of thanksgiving
and people around the country are
traveling to get home
[Music]
in portland oregon
a man under the name of dan cooper pays
20
for the 245 flight
to seattle tacoma
flight 305 is one of the shortest
journeys on northwest orient schedules
just a half an hour in normal conditions
[Music]
there are no security or identity checks
on domestic flights
so in 1971 it was possible to board an
airplane carrying a gun carrying a bomb
carrying knives carrying weapons nobody
checked you could just get on and go as
dan cooper did
the slim man in his mid-40s is wearing
mirrored sunglasses
and dressed like a typical businessman
[Music]
he takes his seat at the back of the
plane
okay
[Music]
on takeoff the man hands florence an
envelope
at first she thinks he's flirting
but his insistent gaze persuades her to
open the envelope
the note reads
miss
i have a bomb here and would like you to
sit by me
the shocked stewardess asks the man if
he's serious
she calls her colleague tina muklow
inside the hijacker's briefcase
he reveals what appears to be
a bomb
he holds the bare ends of two wires
threatening to blow up the plane
unless his demands are met
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the hijacking is relayed to the control
tower
northwest orient and the fbi are alerted
the dispatcher told me that there had
been a hijacking of a northwest airliner
at the portland airport
and to get their pronto
meanwhile
cooper makes his demands
he wants 200 000
placed in a knapsack
he also wants four parachutes
two main back shoots and two safety
front shoots
the terrified attendant
takes both notes forward to the captain
later
cooper will demand these notes back
northwest orient quickly agrees to the
demands
fbi agents contact sea first bank in
seattle
the bank provides money
with pre-recorded serial numbers
the man calling himself dan cooper
seems calm
sipping his bourbon
while smoking his way through nearly
half a pack
of raleigh cigarettes
later
florence shaffner would even say that
the man seemed rather nice
finally the ransom money and parachutes
arrive at the airport
copy brand 305.
[Music]
cooper insists that they taxi to a
remote part of the runway
[Music]
[Music]
cooper failed to specify the
denomination of the ransom
money and the two hundred thousand
dollars
is made up of twenty dollar bills
it weighs 23 pounds
[Music]
the passengers
still unaware of the threat are released
along with two attendants
including florence shafter
the rest of the flight crew
remains captive
the plane is refueled
and cleared for takeoff
the hijacker demands that they fly at 10
000 feet
with landing gear and flaps down
the plane speed will be limited to
around 200 miles per hour
he wants to fly to mexico city
tina
we cannot make it to mexico but there's
not enough fuel on board we can't make
it to mexico city it's too far the
captain offers reno or phoenix
[Music]
the autopilot is set on flight path
victor 23
which allows for low altitude flying
meanwhile two air force jets shadow the
plane
but they can't maintain such a low speed
and have to circle around the hijacked
plane
cooper orders tina muklow
to join her colleagues in the cockpit
tina notices that cooper is tying
something around his waist
she thinks he's attaching the bag of
money to himself
[Music]
captain i have an indication of the aft
stairway door has been opened
the warning light indicates that the
rear door and stairs have been deployed
a boeing 727
is one of the only commercial planes
with rear stairs
in 1971
there's nothing to stop them being
deployed during flight
the crew are terrified that cooper will
jump then detonate the bomb still on
board
[Music]
uh captain we're losing pressure we are
losing cabin pressure
exactly what happens next
has been in debate for nearly 40 years
the only clear thing
is that dan cooper
was never seen
or heard from again
today
the fbi is recruiting the public to help
catch the thief
applying new technology
to old evidence
and even recreating the jump
in the hope of finally discovering
the fate of d.b cooper
in the seattle office of the fbi
special agent larry carr
is taking a new look
at the case of d.b cooper
this is the only hijacking in the united
states that has been unsolved
we have very long memories in the fbi uh
and we like to be 100 successful
so we're determined to do the best we
can to solve the case
agent carr is for the first time in fbi
history
recruiting the help of the public
these citizen sleuths
have offered their services for free
in the hope of finally solving the
mystery
of d.b cooper
paleontologist tom k
could soon uncover new secrets from
cooper's tie left on board
microscopic fibers might prove where he
lived
we're hoping this will put us on the
trail from where cooper came from
but first
the team scrutinizes every detail of the
original investigation
by the time the hijacked plane landed in
reno
dozens of agents were already on the
case
nobody believed that he was going to
jump and the fact that the plane arrived
in reno and he was not on it was
surprising to everybody
all that was recovered from the plane
was a black tie and tie pin
a sports parachute and an open safety
chute
plus cooper's cigarette butts
the glass heat handled is mixed up with
others
and never identified everything else it
seems
dan cooper has taken with him
the ransom notes
the homemade bomb
and the money
have all disappeared
overnight an fbi composite sketch is
drawn from witness statements
[Music]
boeing aviation experts
calculate dan cooper's drop zone
the plane was on autopilot so the exact
flight path is known
[Music]
but exactly when
did dan cooper jump
agents pour over the captain's report
the most likely moment
is when the pressure change was reported
at around 8 10.
[Music]
factoring in the strong westerly winds
creates a huge search area of 28 square
miles
at first light on thanksgiving 1971
just outside ariel washington
one of the biggest manhunts in u.s
history
begins
[Music]
[Music]
helicopters and spotter planes
assist scores of fbi agents and national
guardsmen
the military
got involved with a number of troops
and the fbi had 30 to 40 agents involved
in the search
for weeks the team combs the forests and
farmlands around ariel
but find nothing
dead or alive
dan cooper
has seemingly vanished
when he got on a plane in portland
oregon last night he was just another
passenger who gave his name as d.a
cooper but today after hijacking a
northwest airlines jet ransoming the
passengers in seattle then making a
getaway by parachute somewhere between
there and reno nevada the description on
one wire service
master criminal
in one newspaper the hijacker is
mistakenly named d.b cooper we corrected
him and told him the guy's name was
dan cooper
but
db is catchier than dan so
the name stuck with him forever
initially the fbi concludes that the
hijacker was probably an experienced
parachutist the fact that he did jump
certainly says that he is someone who is
much more familiar with aircraft and
with parachuting than the average person
agents check records of hundreds of
ex-paratroopers and pilots
in the hope of finding their man
then
a breakthrough
[Music]
an almost identical skyjacking
convinces the fbi
that d.b cooper has struck again
on april 7 1972
a man under the alias james johnson
hijacks a united airlines boeing 727
he demands half a million dollars four
parachutes
and leaps out from the aft stairs
somewhere over utah
the hijacker might have gotten away with
it had he not previously boasted to an
acquaintance
he claimed that he could have done the
db cooper heist but would have asked for
half a million dollars
on a tip the fbi storms the home of
richard mccoy
an ex-vietnam pilot
married with two small children
in a cupboard they find a jumpsuit and a
duffel bag filled with half a million
dollars
mccoy is arrested on suspicion of both
hijackings
but the fbi finds no evidence to connect
mccoy with the cooper crime mccoy's
picture was shown to the witnesses that
had interaction with db cooper and said
no that's not him
mccoy is found guilty of the united
hijacking
and sentenced to 45 years in state
penitentiary
but the fact that he survived the leap
from a commercial plane
adds to growing opinion that d.v cooper
also lived on
then
in 1980
after almost a decade of dead ends
a major
[Music]
breakthrough on february 7th
brian ingram and his father dwayne
collect firewood on the banks of the
columbia river
suddenly brian feels something buried in
the sand
when i come across the the edge of it
it's like you know well let me get this
out of the way what is this junk you
know pulling it up out of there and then
it's like wait a minute what the heck do
we have here
the young boy uncovers three bundles of
moldy cash
with the rubber bands still intact
the father and son turn it into the fbi
some of the bills are impossible to
identify
but most in the middle of the bundle are
legible
the serial numbers are checked against
the money stolen by dan cooper
it's a match
fifty eight hundred dollars from the
original two hundred thousand dollar
ransom money
but the new find confuses the fbi
the money was outside of the area that
we felt was the
the search area so
how it got there was something that we
puzzled a little bit over and of course
didn't have an answer to
[Music]
the money is found more than 20 miles
from dan cooper's drop zone
and in the opposite direction from where
the wind was blowing
[Music]
to add to the confusion
geologists determine that the money is
sitting above an area dredged in 1974
it means that the bundles of cash
arrived at least three years after the
hijacking in 1971.
the chances of it taking so long to
travel via river
seem implausible
many people jump to the conclusion
that cooper returned
to bury the money
perhaps to provoke the fbi
after digging up a huge area
the fbi finds no more money and no
further clues
nine years after the hijacking
the case remains unsolved
today this sleepy town of just a few
hundred people
is the mecca
of the legend of d.b cooper
here at the general store
every year since 1974
a party is held in cooper's honor
on the saturday after thanksgiving
people from all over the country
come to pay tribute to the man they
believe got away with it
[Music]
[Applause]
he put ariel washington on the map he
can you imagine how ballsy it is to jump
out of a 727 in a rainstorm at night
wearing loafers that's one tough ass
dude
to this day i think he's still alive i
think the devi cooper is sitting on the
beach in mexico
drinking and having a good time yes
truthfully you're not d.b cooper right
i ain't gonna tell nobody nothing my
name is dan cooper
i wish okay where's all that money honey
over the years the story of d.b cooper
has grown to almost mythic status
he's inspired books
songs
documentaries movies
and even aviation regulations
[Applause]
1971 was the era of vietnam and civil
rights protests
it generated a mood of distrust
towards authority
people tended to root for people who
would strike out against authority
d.b cooper to that extent
was a excellent symbol
d.b cooper was a modern-day pirate of
the sky and in a way he he did something
an act that was so daredevil that he
became a fixture in the collective
imagination of the country
this was not a common hoodlum
he dressed in a business suit
he had an attache case
he drank bourbon
he was to those degrees gentlemanly
the way that james bond was a gentleman
secret agent
d.b cooper attempted to be
a gentleman thief
who was dan cooper
gentleman thief or
violent criminal
despite evidence to the contrary
some of cooper's old adversaries in the
fbi
would like to believe he is nothing but
a common criminal
he probably was just another old khan
he talked like an old khan he used
filthy language
he was of an age
that he had probably lived a life of
crime and he was a loser
but there's little in witness statements
to support himmelsbach's claims
some stories in the media portrayed
cooper as a chain smoker
and a drinker
it's an image that larry carr thinks is
wrong
i don't believe db cooper was a drinker
hardly at all
you would think that someone
that was going to be in a very stressful
situation would certainly have more than
one drink if he was a drinker and
certainly would have smoked many many
more cigarettes than just the eight that
he did
carr finds a profile of the typical
raleigh cigarette smoker
he was upscale
and well educated
likewise carr finds that bourbon and 7up
was popular with a sophisticated crowd
in the 70s
if cooper was a gentleman thief
money wasn't his only motive
at one point in the flight
tina muklow asked cooper why he'd picked
on northwest orient
he replied
it's not that i have a grudge against
your airline
i just have a grudge
[Music]
it's these conflicting portraits
that have kept the legend alive
we don't know if he lives or if he dies
that adds to the mystery
[Music]
it's like having a novel without a final
chapter
we want to know how it turns out
over the years
the fbi have interviewed over a thousand
suspects
but finding cooper
has always eluded them
[Music]
then in 2007
a new suspect emerges
that seems particularly credible
[Music]
the source is a new york private
investigator
skip porteous
porteous has been contacted by a man
claiming to know the identity
of d.b cooper
i asked him what's this all about and he
said i know who d.b cooper was
and i said how do you know that and he
said well i grew up with him he was my
brother
porteous finds a number of parallels
between new suspect kenneth christensen
and d.b
cooper at the time of the cooper
hijacking kenneth christensen was a
flight attendant for northwest orient
airlines he knew the planes and he knew
the schedules
[Music]
in the early 70s christensen has some
grievance over redundancies and pay cuts
[Music]
at the time he's making around 150 a
week
just a year after the 1971 skyjack
christensen purchases a large south
washington house
in cash
it's a huge amount to have saved from
his modest paycheck
christensen like cooper is a bourbon
drinker and a regular smoker
there's also a resemblance to the sketch
of dan cooper
[Music]
schaffner is shown christensen's
photograph
she said it looks more like d.b cooper
than any other photo she's ever seen
but this evidence has not convinced the
fbi
he never admitted that he was dan cooper
it's just a relative saying i think he's
dan cooper with nothing to show that he
possibly is dan cooper
stories like christensen have kept the
legend of db cooper alive for decades
now
the daring jump will be recreated
in the hope of discovering
if cooper survived
[Music]
today
all the evidence from the cooper case
fits into this small box
the open parachute
and pack
the tie
and tie pin
the plane ticket and samples of the
recovered money
are all that remains
now the case is being re-examined
in the hope that modern police methods
can reveal new clues
[Music]
paleontologist tom k
is lending his services to the
investigation
and has become the lead citizen
scientist
his examination of the tie reveals a new
secret
small particles of pollen
pollen means that this is where this tie
was in the spring not in november when
he jumped
if we could track the species of pollen
and these species are rare enough it
could tell us where he came from
there are thousands of varieties of
pollen
if the right one is identified
it could add a vital piece
to a complex puzzle
but the most promising evidence remains
the three bundles of ransom money found
on the riverbank
it's the only piece of the puzzle we
have of what might have happened after
he left the plane
so it tells its own story
if carr and his team determine how the
money got there and when
it could help answer the most important
question
did cooper survive
in 1980 the fbi concluded that the money
was sitting above a dredge layer and
must have arrived after 1974.
it led many to believe that dan cooper
returned to bury the money
but tom k is convinced that the money
came out of the river
and wasn't buried by human hands
[Music]
tom and his team visit the banks of the
columbia river
where the bundles of cash were found
agent carr joins them
using land measurements
gps
satellite and archive photographs
the team make a major new discovery
they find the dredging of 1974 stopped
150 feet away from where the money was
found
so we believe now that the dredging
sands did not interfere with the
original burial of the money and that
the money got buried there within a few
months after cooper's daring jump
if the money was not buried by cooper
and came out of the river within a few
months
how did it travel over 20 miles from the
drop zone
the new evidence points to one
conclusion
the only transport method that makes any
sense
is via water
did the bag of money land in a nearby
river
was it still attached to dan cooper
did the hijacker have the skills
to complete his mission
back in 1971
the fbi spent thousands of man-hours
looking for a suspect with aviation and
skydiving expertise
but found nothing
now
larry carr thinks they might have got it
wrong
when we started breaking down the actual
events of the night the choices he made
it started defining someone different
than that picture
[Music]
dan cooper had brought no specialist
clothing to make the daring night jump
[Music]
and because he failed to specify the
denomination of the ransom money
he carried extra weight
[Music]
that's 20 pounds of money attached to
him
if he had asked for hundreds he would
have had around five pounds of money a
huge difference but yet he didn't make
those requests
the man who packed the two main
parachutes in 1971
is convinced that dan cooper was not a
skydiver
[Music]
on that night i provided two parachutes
one of them being an nb8 which is the
one i'm wearing
and the other was a pioneer sport
parachute
[Music]
he chose the nv8 and i don't know why
the nba8 is very uncomfortable will open
much harder
the rip cord is very flat it's mixed in
with a harness
so
he couldn't probably even find the rip
cord
much was against cooper that november
night
visibility was poor
the wind factor was well below freezing
and cooper had no goggles or gloves
why in the world would a guy jump with
an nb8 at night
going out of a 727 not knowing where
he's getting out
didn't make any sense to me
on board the hijacked plane
the parachutes were delivered with a set
of instructions
dan cooper told tina muklow
he wouldn't need them
this detail convinced many
that cooper was an experienced
parachutist
i think that there's a lot of good
reasons to think that he's still alive
you can find parachute experts out there
who said that they can make those jumps
professional skydiver troy hartman
agrees to a simulation test jump
he is dressed as witnesses described dan
cooper
[Music]
a 23 pound weight is added in a front
pack
and he is asked to tumble
to simulate the disorientation that
cooper might have felt in the dark
but cooper's worst enemy can't be
simulated
the cold
numerous times i've had the problem of
of not being able to get a good grip on
the handle because it's cold
you start to panic you start to do
things faster than you would in normal
conditions
troy remains convinced that cooper knew
enough to open his chute
in its absolute simplest form
you need to pull a handle
and that old gear was designed to allow
the parachute to come out even if you're
tumbling
so
i definitely think he got a parachute
open
but even if dan cooper deployed his
shoot
did he survive
the landing
the mystery of db cooper
has fascinated people
and frustrated the fbi for nearly 40
years
scientist tom k
believes the three bundles of ransom
money provide the best clue to solving
cooper's fate
apart from the fifty eight hundred
dollars found on the riverbank
none of the other bills were ever found
in circulation
tom is convinced that the bag of money
all two hundred thousand dollars of it
must have traveled by river to where the
three stacks of money were found
the three bundles couldn't have traveled
independently yet ended up in the same
place on the sandbar
this tells us that the bank bag was
involved in the transport
it could have split open close to the
sandbar thereby increasing the odds that
three out of the hundred bundles of cash
would have ended up together in the same
place
if the bank bag ended up in the river
then whatever happened to cooper
the money he risked his life to steal
was never spent
[Music]
but how exactly did the bag of money end
up in the water
tom examines the flight path
and timing of the jump
recorded at approximately 8 10.
at this point he's directly over the
lewis river
if the bank bag which was being flailed
by 200 mile an hour winds detached from
cooper it would have fallen directly
below into the lewis river
the lewis river is around 300 feet wide
with a fast current and rapids
it's possible that the money bag could
make its way downstream
but dan cooper was protecting the money
with his
life and with 30 feet of parachute cord
could have secured the bag
if cooper did secure the bag
and managed to deploy his
shoe where would he have landed
his chosen parachute the nb8
unlike the sport chute is not
maneuverable
[Music]
it would take him wherever the winds
blew
tom k believes that whatever altitude
cooper deployed
the westerly winds would carry him
directly to his worst nightmare
water
from our calculations we can determine
that if cooper pulled his parachute
right away he would have had a long
drift and likely ended up in lake merwin
if he waited and pulled a couple
thousand feet above the ground he would
have ended up in the lewis river
lake merwin is a huge dam
which spills directly into the lewis
river
the low cloud cover
and the non-maneuverable parachute would
have given cooper little if any chance
of changing course
with near freezing temperatures
the water would have been cold
cold enough
to kill
[Music]
when db cooper hit the water like we
believe he did
he would have only had a matter of
minutes in that type of cold water to
get off on shore at that point remember
he was laden with 20 pounds of money he
had a harness and he had a long
parachute attached to him at this point
so we think that his odds of survival
would have been very low
he used the poor choice of equipment
the conditions were horrible
and the fact that we haven't found
anything
really leads me to believe
that he died that night
[Music]
the semi-buoyant body would have moved
down the fast running river
some 20 miles
to the columbia
the three bundles of ransom cash were
found just a few miles from where the
louis and columbia rivers meet
[Music]
but there's a catch
these few miles are upriver against its
natural flow
[Music]
tom k offers a rational explanation
at the time
the columbia river was one of the
busiest shipping lanes in north america
we believe it's possible that cooper's
body and the money
became snagged up on one of these ships
propellers
and it moved upstream with the ship
at some point the violence of this
ripped open the bank bag and spilled out
the money
[Music]
three of the hundred bundles
subsequently found their way onto the
shore
before being covered by the shifting
sands
but if this is true
what happened to cooper's body
looked at the currents and these tell us
that within a few days the columbia
river is going to suck up your body and
spit it out into the ocean so db cooper
may be at the bottom of the ocean at
this point and we would never ever be
able to come up with this body
after nearly four decades
tom k offers the first comprehensive
theory
of what might have happened to dan
cooper
but
dead or alive the identity of the
hijacker
remains a mystery
larry carr believes he might have a new
lead
a european comic book hero of the 1960s
is a fearless pilot called
dan cooper
the dashing hero carries out brave
missions
including parachuting from planes
it's possible that the skyjacker was a
fan of the comic and used the alias for
his crime
maybe someone that never even thought of
their relative as being dan cooper but
disappeared in 1971 and they're
searching in the attic and also they
find these comic books uh from dan
cooper
i mean that would be huge
but tom k knows what evidence they will
need to convince people
that the legendary dan cooper died that
night
well really what it's going to take to
solve the db cooper case is d.b cooper's
body
it's kind of like bigfoot you know you
can come up with lots of evidence until
you have a dead body you really haven't
solved the case
while probability now points to db
cooper's death
without hard evidence
many people today still believe that he
survived
i say there's a good possibility that
dan cooper survived the jump and is out
there
the legend of d.b cooper
has it that he was a gentleman thief
that he stole 200 000
without hurting anyone and leapt into
the darkness
and into history
whatever the truth
it is not the end of the story it's more
like
a new beginning
to solving the mystery of d.b cooper
[Music]
you